You guys know that I try my best to stay
out of the day to day political
bickering and focus more on big ideas
and the philosophies which are behind
all the fighting.
This doesn't mean I'm ignoring the
issues of the moment,
be it North Korea,
the gun debate or the general state of
Trumpism,
but focusing on why people believe what
they believe is far more valuable to me
than adding fuel to the fire of whatever
the story of the day might be.
Toss in a healthy dose of political
gridlock and we seem to have lots of
people who were yelling,
but very few people who are doing.
There's one issue happening in American
politics right now,
which is a great example of the
stagnation we face,
but that is totally flying under the
radar right now.
Dozens of countries,
some of them key strategic allies don't
have us ambassadors because the Senate
has refused to vote on their
confirmation.
According to the rules of the Senate
right now,
the Senate needs 30 hours of debate to
confirm an ambassadorship.
You can imagine with all the nonsensical
waste in DC,
how impossible it would be to spend 30
hours debating each of the new
ambassador ships.
When a new administration comes in,
we'd be talking about literally
thousands of hours of debate for a
branch of government which can't seem to
agree on which flavor of yogurt should
be served at the capital hill
commissary.
Back in 2014 when the Democrats
controlled the Senate,
then majority leader,
Harry Reid used what is known as the
nuclear option to get many Obama
appointees through the Senate in effect
read,
change the rules so that a simple
majority rather than a 60 vote super
majority would be enough to confirm
ambassadors,
federal judges,
and other positions.
Though I was firmly on the left at the
time and I had no issue,
I can remember with the Obama
appointees,
I was against read using such a drastic
tactic.
To me,
if you change the rules when you're in
power,
it's incredibly obvious and probably
quite deserved when those same rules
will be used against your team.
When you're not in power,
you can rightly blame Republicans for
not voting.
On the Obama appointees in 2014,
just as right now,
you can rightly blame Democrats for not
voting on trump appointees in 2018.
This is exactly why people rightfully
hate the political machine in
Washington.
It either does nothing or it changes the
rules to suit itself while usually
leaving the people it's supposed to
serve far behind the Republicans now led
by majority leader,
Mitch Mcconnell could use what is known
as the nuclear option right now just as
Reid and the Democrats did back in 2014.
For whatever reason though,
McConnell refuses to do so.
Some were saying he has such an old
school affinity for the rules of the
Senate that he doesn't want to stoop to
what reed did in a certain way.
This seems like a principled position,
but at this point in American politics,
I wonder if clinging onto the old ways
while your ideological opponents chisel
away at those very institutions at every
opportunity makes much sense at all.
Let me add another wrinkle to the story.
The highest ranking ambassadorship that
we now have open Germany has been
offered to former US spokesmen for the
UN,
Richard Grenelle.
Richard is the longest serving UN
spokesman in history,
working for four different US
ambassadors.
He's also served several other positions
in the government as well as worked for
a few other high level political
campaigns by every measure.
He's supremely qualified and I've seen
plenty of people on both sides of the
aisle that praise him as the exact type
of person that we need more of in
politics.
Richard and I have become friends over
the past few years and I can personally
tell you that he's truly a decent guy
who just wants to serve his country.
Oh,
and there's one other piece to this.
Richard happens to be gay.
You may remember back in 2012,
Richard was briefly a spokesman for the
Romney campaign until the media decided
to attack an openly gay man for daring
to work for the Republican candidate,
Mitt Romney thus causing Richard to step
down from the campaign because he didn't
want to be a distraction apparently.
Although Romney felt it was just fine to
hire a gay man,
and Richard felt it was totally okay to
work for Romney.
The media just wouldn't let it be gay
conservatives like Richard,
much like black conservatives like Larry
elder or female conservatives like Nikki
Haley,
challenge the orthodoxy that the
Democrats must own all of these groups
of people I mentioned Richard Sexuality,
not because it's important or even
relevant,
unless you play the identity politics
game as so many do.
In effect,
the Democrats are blocking and extremely
qualified openly gay men from serving
his country aren't the Democrats and
left these supposed to be for gays.
Isn't that part of their intersectional
worldview?
Immutable characteristics,
often trump qualifications.
If you subscribe to this line of
thinking,
shouldn't.
This also means supporting gay people
whose political positions you might
disagree with because you believe in
their ability to think for themselves or
perhaps the so called tolerance side
really isn't pro gay or pro any
minority.
They are actually only pro those who
believe as they do now,
obviously you know that I don't think
anyone should be confirmed because of
their sexuality,
nor should their sexuality matter in the
least when it comes to being nominated
in the first place.
I just think that this particular cases
interesting on so many levels.
We have the gridlock of Washington with
Democrats refusing to vote on trump
nominees.
We have a majority leader,
Mcconnell that refuses to use his option
to confirm nominees even though the
previous Senate leader,
Reid did exactly just that.
We have dozens of qualified candidates
waiting to do their civic duty and we
have just as many countries waiting for
our ambassadors to move there and get to
work cotton.
All of this mess is a good man,
Richard Grinnell,
who I happen to know personally who
doesn't want extra credit for being gay,
but just wants to get to work.
How can you make a difference in all
this?
Call your local senator and ask their
assistant at the office
why they are in voting on these nominees
and you can also call Mitch Mcconnell at
his DC office by calling two.
Oh,
two,
four,
five,
one.
Actually,
I'm going to give him a call right now.
Joining me today as a guy who seen an
awful lot of people get hit in the nuts,
a man who's lived in a house that
constantly seems to be getting fuller
and a standup comic who's new.
Special zero to 60 is now streaming on
Amazon.
Bob Saget,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thank you.
I'm excited to be here.
You're a very smart man.
I cannot keep up with you mentally,
but we did have dinner and I seem to
keep up with the entrees.
Is that why you were applying me with so
much alcohol during dinner to kind of
dumb me down,
so I just said that we could get on the
level.
I wanted to see what you were like
unconscious.
Yeah,
we did go because that's the world we're
in right now.
Yeah.
That's it.
Opposite day kind of statement.
In other words,
years ago when you would say,
I want to see what your unconscious.
That would be a joke,
but unfortunately we are in a world
right now where that's actually
happened.
So a lot of things that are a reverend
and could be considered funny or not.
And so there's this buffering that goes
on before,
but either way you did not get overly
inebriated and you were more than
pleasant.
And we had a lovely night with both of
our significant others who we both adore
and we laughed and we had good food.
Yeah,
we will do it again.
We will do it again.
And that's all I want to talk about.
Talking about my career.
What do we have his entree,
I believe.
Uh,
I had the fish.
You did.
I think you had something not as
healthy.
I think it was.
Maybe you had some kind of chicken.
So I'm to maybe.
Alright,
let's focus here and say I get.
So I'm here.
That's a good place to start.
What you just did there.
Just the state of political correctness.
Let's just do a little bit on that.
And then I want to do saget one-on-one.
Alright.
For this next hour,
I'm teaching that course at a community
college.
How many kids are taking it?
It doesn't matter.
Whoever applies.
That doesn't turn me in.
I'm all in.
Everybody comes in to the trailer.
What do you think of a that you're doing
this?
We're live to tape so we don't edit and
this did not exist four years ago.
This existed,
but it didn't exist like this.
I mean,
you've got millions of people that watch
this.
Yeah.
This is crazy.
Well,
what do you think about that?
Like you're used to doing.
I mean obviously I went to stand up and
everything else,
but you do scripted series,
you guys,
you do movies,
things like that,
but you also do you do panel on talk
shows,
things that are sort of,
they're kind of old school now.
Like that's very different than coming
in here and right before we start I said
to you,
we're just going to go for it.
And you were like,
whatever you want.
I mean,
I don't have to look.
I can just do that and we're,
we're,
you can.
Yeah.
Well you get a little bit back again and
better.
Those are the smallest cards I've ever
seen your interviews on.
Microfiche.
It's just,
I just write little silly things or.
No,
that looks all smart.
Um,
I,
I love the fact that this exists because
years ago,
if you wanted to go on a show and have a
one on one with someone,
it was,
you were a baby,
but it was Tom Snyder and we'd be
getting that,
uh,
that you might be tiny bit older than a
baby.
The camera was always very close to,
is incredibly close and Dan Akroyd on
Saturday night live and the very
beginning we do an impression of it was
this tight and he would be smoking and
Tom and just talking to camera do is
discourse which is very much like a
podcast is today.
Like bill burr friend of mine gets up in
the morning,
talks for an hour once a week.
It's unbelievable to listen to a lot of
our great podcasters.
That's the,
everything has changed.
And in that regard,
this has changed for the better because
you get to have an articulate
conversation,
um,
that you can't normally have in
commercial television because commercial
televisions meant to be entertaining.
Yeah.
Only I don't know what we're meant to be
over here.
Well,
interesting.
Interesting.
I guess.
Yeah.
And my fiance,
Kelly turned me onto your show and um,
I said I really like him and I like what
he's talking about.
And you had guests on and you wherever
you're able to be a diplomat,
a,
which is very difficult to do when you
have people with different points of
view.
A conservative and a liberal,
which I don't understand.
I don't understand any of it.
I mean I understand it,
but I mean we're mammals,
whereas opposed to alive,
we're supposed to be nice to another
mammal,
I suppose to hunt it and kill it depends
which kind of mammal you are.
If it's delicious then you have to go
for it.
Yeah.
Just food.
Well we're gonna we're gonna dive into
all that because I did notice that for
you it's interesting I think because
your standup is so different than your,
your television persona between
Americans money.
So the video is in full as well that the
old ones.
But then entourage that was Kinda like a
thing.
But then.
But then I did a bunch of acting stuff
too.
And I've done Broadway work,
which was,
some of it was similar to my standup,
but I've always done some mean that's
every seven years.
There's some new incarnation that people
go,
who the hell is he?
Yeah,
well that's why I think it's interesting
because especially with celebrities,
people like to just get an or anyone
that's public that they like to just get
a kind of image of you and then just run
with that forever and challenging that.
I refuse to be pigeonholed because it
sounds like something you should not do
to little pigeon now.
See that's the kind of joke you guys
still do.
You still do that because it's not a
human being.
It's a pigeon,
but the only people that are going to be
really upset about that would be the
humane society and they are right.
They spcas all over the show.
They're just.
I don't see their name anywhere anymore.
I think they're out.
You think they're done?
I don't know.
I think it's the Aas,
PCA,
NRA.
I think it's a combined so that you take
care of the bird and then you fire at
it.
Is that going to fly well on this show?
I think it will know we've got those
chickens out there in one day.
People always ask me,
what are you going to do when they stop
laying eggs or you just wait a minute,
but they're so beautiful.
I thought they were males because they
had the red millet.
Millay millay was to call you.
We're very excited to say Kako.
I said you have three beautiful Cox,
but no,
those are actually.
Those are female hens that lay eggs and
what are you doing this for?
The eggs,
not just as woody Allen,
which was Groucho Marx.
I need the eggs and the eggs,
but that's the truth.
Andy Hall.
That's the right.
Go ahead.
I.
This is a problem with me as a talk show
guest.
As a comedian.
Yeah,
and as someone without a script,
I free associate and I sometimes do not
stay on track,
but you were so smart and linear.
You were going to keep me on track and I
will do my very best to accommodate you
and I will do my best to accommodate.
You said,
okay,
this is fair.
Let's start at the beginning.
You were born in Philadelphia?
I was,
yeah,
in Einstein Hospital.
Einstein hospital.
And it's still there.
Is that an honor of Albert Einstein?
It is.
And it's on broad street and uh,
and I was born there and my dad worked
for a supermarket company called Food
Pantry,
pride supermarkets.
And he was an executive.
That all sounds legit.
What about your family?
What,
what background?
What business were they in?
I was born in Brooklyn,
grew up in Long Island,
lived in Manhattan my whole life.
Went to college,
upstate New York.
So I'm a true New Yorker.
So we're both.
You had the life I wish I had.
I was in Philly.
I lived at home during college.
You had it.
You had.
This is why you are smart.
And I go out and tell a bunch of wiener
jokes.
I know,
but I'm going back into that now.
As you know,
you are,
you're out doing stand up.
I told you I'm going back into standup.
You were very excited.
I'm excited.
You also told me you were playing the
Irvine Improv and when is that?
Oh,
that wasn't even public just now.
That's great.
Is that okay to say that April eighth,
April my first headlining Gig in 10
years.
And this is one of the nicest clubs in
Los Angeles and in,
in,
in anywhere really.
I mean it's,
it's like 600 people,
700 people.
It looks like a spaceship.
It looks like a Disney exhibit and it's
um,
it's an irvine,
which is why they call it the Irvine
Improv and couldn't put that together.
Why do they call it the Irvine Improv
and there's spit,
I don't know,
but they're smart people and uh,
and then nice people.
Maybe you will bring some more people
because you have so many people that you
will bring your audience,
which is,
that's the advantage of what we do and
whatever we do,
whatever media we're on,
that's who comes to see us.
That's got to be the most beautiful
shift in comedy.
Right.
Do you remember that moment when you
went from being a guy that was just
trying to get on eight out of 10 comics
at the end of the night?
Nobody knows who you are.
Do you remember the beginning of when
people were going,
I'm going to see Bob Saget.
Something weird happened with me,
which was I started doing standup when I
was 17 and I want to hear that.
That was a re heal.
Who uh,
the 70,
73.
Wow.
So because I'm 104 on the freeway.
Head of hair though for $100.
Not Bad.
No.
Very impressed.
But I had to do the drops.
I take the thing.
I take propecia that's supposed to take
on the probation.
He seems fine.
Oh,
please don't compare me to that.
That's the hair.
We'll get there.
We'll get my.
It's not a comb over.
I know it's going to happen if we get
right on trump.
I actually,
I,
I believe,
but I don't want to.
I'm not doing.
I'm not doing anything to bash anyone.
I will not do it even though it's
possible that his comb-over is from an
onion in the kitchen that just snaggle
tooth along the ground and then crawls
up his back.
Did you see that moment when I saw that
video on the airplane that done CGI?
Was that done with effects because that
didn't look possible?
It looks pretty.
It looked pretty fake.
But let's,
let's put trump aside.
I want to talk stand.
Yes,
because.
Do you remember that moment when,
when things change?
Yeah.
What happened was I came out to la.
I went on,
I had one,
the Student Academy Award for a
documentary I made about my nephew who
had his face reconstructed,
um,
when he was seven and I won this student
Academy Award for documentary and then I
went on at the comedy store the next
night and Mitzi the owner of the comedy
store.
So you should work here.
So I started getting spots right away.
Wow.
And then I started a fight for that.
People fight and I didn't work the door.
Wow.
And I was,
I guess the likable but strange,
very strange jokes.
Like my first joke was I have the first
show,
I have the brain of a German shepherd
and the body of a 16 year old boy and
they're both in my car and I want you to
see them now.
It's just an odd rambling,
but it symbolizes,
I think it answers the question of how
did he become this because he was that
you're going to be third person.
I myself,
but um,
and then I started going on a college
tour.
She put me on a Mitzi shore for the
comedy store,
put me on a college tour and I was a
guitar act just to parodies and I would
sing while my guitar gently weeps,
turn a valve and water poured out of the
guitar and you could only see it in the
first 10 rows.
So it doesn't really work for the big
stadium.
CanNot play the Irvine Improv with this
bit.
Yeah.
And then I was headlining right away.
So in my early twenties,
I'd go out on the road while I was
taking five years of acting classes with
a teacher named Darryl Hickman and La
while I was doing improv classes at the
groundlings while I was doing spots at
the comedy store.
I'd go out on the road and then headline
and then make money.
Um,
but not enough to get a career.
And then it was like eight,
nine years of hosting the comedy store
in Westwood and that was hard.
It was,
but I got to be friend people that I
worshiped,
which were Richard Pryor and Robin
Williams and David Letterman was one of
my first emcees and,
and so I was 22 years old and the place
was packed like it was then kind of now
bad sentence.
But in the early eighties it was you
could not get into any room and every
single person on the lineup was like.
And I was hosting a lot of the shows,
so,
uh,
but then everybody went off and got tv
shows and I was still at the comedy
store hosting and thinking,
this is it.
I'm never going to make it.
And then I got an,
a Richard Pryor movie and then I got on
a cbs show and a morning show or movie a
critical condition.
Oh,
I've seen that on the young Dr Jaffe who
does all the jobs that are disgusting
that he doesn't want to do because he's
not a real doctor.
It sounds like the emcee at a comedy
club.
Exactly the same thing,
you don't want to touch people and um,
I remember holding Garrett Morris from
Saturday night live by the testicles and
Richard kept calling me,
kept telling me to squeeze harder and
that was a reshoot.
They added me to that scene.
I can see them when you talk about it
sort of,
and I've had this with a couple of other
comics that were around at that time.
There's like a real nostalgia for it.
Do you remember thinking it was a
special that was yet,
but you remember it at the time thinking
like,
I'm really in 100 percent because
usually people don't like the good old
days.
You only remember them as well.
They weren't good old days.
Yeah,
because you know,
you're,
you're in a place that is,
you know,
in the comedy stars a lot of history and
it Ciro's is the main room and there's
supposed to be ghosts in there and Sam
Kennison says Esau quarter floating in
the air of a dead mobster or something.
And I believe all of it.
Um,
I spent a lot of time in there,
uh,
and it was struggling,
you know,
you'd have people come and see you.
Rodney dangerfield was kind to me,
put me on a young comedian special,
but it was all,
you know,
what I was the warmup comic for Bosom
Buddies with Tom Hanks and Gary and um,
it was all struggling,
you know,
but,
but you need it.
But,
and I used to wait in line in New York
at him at the Improv and catch a rising
star for 10 hours a sign.
The lineup sheet.
We'll wait for 10,
12 hours.
And I think there's something if you
come out of the Dugout,
if you really are the trenches are dug
outs fine.
You're gonna,
you're gonna,
you're gonna bat maybe.
But,
um,
but if you come out of the trenches and
you,
you go through it,
it's almost,
oh,
guy had a heart attack of the audience.
I've had that happen before,
you know,
oh,
this guy's getting thrown.
Oh,
this guy's got a gun.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
That happened to me in Cleveland.
I remember that.
It gets to the point where you're almost
a pilot on a plane,
you know,
it's like,
I'm ready for anything,
but when you want to do is make people
laugh.
And that was the hardest transition for
me was to take off the guitar and to
learn to be a comedian.
And um,
so I.
What was that moment like for you?
Really hard.
Um,
I had a guitar on for like four years.
I took it off and um,
I bombed for a long time.
I would do it.
I used the club for what it was supposed
to be used for,
but it didn't surprise me.
It didn't help me get a sitcom if people
saw me and they went,
he's amicable but he's not funny and I
was trying to do jokes and a lot of them
were.
There was a talent coordinator for the
tonight show I could never get on as a
comic.
I got on to do panel with Johnny Carson,
thanks to Gary Shandling for putting me
on the first time.
And then Jay Leno,
I was on once with him but that I was on
with carson 13,
14 times.
And then in and always panel,
but I never went on as a comedian
because this talent coordinator who
passed on named Jim Mccauley who helped
a lot of people's careers,
um,
except mind.
But he did help me in a way.
He said you're very funny,
but your act is like a stone skipping on
the water.
It never really digs in.
Oh,
thank you.
Wow.
That's something to really take Kung Fu.
Thank you.
Master.
Take the pebble from my hand.
So it,
it hurt me because I couldn't get on the
damn show,
but I wasn't,
I really wasn't meant to.
I mean,
I hate to say those kinds of words,
you know,
it's not meant to be or whatever,
but it was hell of a lot better to sit
there and todd,
a couple of segments with Johnny Carson
and him like me and be able to talk to a
guy that you looked up to so much
because he was kind of a master like
that.
Like I'm emanating true jealousy.
Whenever I hear any of you guys talk
about Carson,
it's like that.
And I'm not even making this up because
I'm not delusional.
He liked me and I still can't figure
that out.
But I would go,
I would say something like,
and I,
David Letterman had a lot of his amazing
qualities and it would respond the same
way to this because one of my patterns
that I would say is,
this is true.
And Johnny would go,
I don't care.
I don't care if it's true,
just tell it wouldn't be the same thing
would go on letterman.
And I would go,
this is true.
He goes,
I don't care if it's true or not.
It just make it funny.
Just say it.
I'm blanking on the title of Bill
Maher's first book,
the novel that he wrote about standup.
Um,
but the first line in it,
he says something about this is true,
which is exactly what a comic says when
they were about to tell you something
false.
Correct.
And that's how that,
that's how the novel the Hell is the
name of the book.
I'll get it in a second.
You should know I should.
This guy should I know him.
I saw a picture,
a,
we are deleted in reading each other's
books.
He has a red mine.
Either.
True story is the name of the book.
Oh,
true story.
That's a bread.
And also think about this,
but seriously folks,
that is the segue into your next job,
our bob hope.
I want to tell you.
So anyway,
that's always good.
But these are all the same anyway,
so I'm in the car.
We,
you do learn tricks and it's always,
if you can kill them with kindness or if
you can fake sincerity with air guys
during that because everyone,
everyone talks about.
It's like you could,
we could literally spend the next hour
with you just naming all stars,
right?
You can just do that.
But were there guys drop name drop for
the next and they,
it'll be very easy to make a promo.
I'll do that.
Professor Irwin Corey.
See?
No one will know that.
Well I know,
but yeah.
But um,
but were there guys that you thought
were true?
Bill Hicks transcendent?
Yeah.
So it of like Bill Hicks,
that's transcendent.
Yeah,
that's the guy who a worship Sam
Kennison,
who was a friend of mine.
I got Ms.
I got Sam is for a spot at the comedy
store.
Was it in the documentary?
No,
but,
um,
he was,
he was an unusual thing.
It was an anomaly.
It was,
no one had ever seen that before.
And Bill Hicks really thought about why
are we here?
And um,
had a sweet philosopher in him,
had,
it was a,
a gentle George Carlin kind of thing.
That was it.
I mean,
from a gentler version I did because I,
I knew him,
he,
he and he was kind of,
I knew him when he was really young.
I met him when he was like 18 or
something or 19 and he hated it.
He kind of took to me and,
and um,
his loss was very sad.
It would have loved to have seen what he
would have arrived at.
Yeah.
If he'd been,
he died very young.
He was,
that's the type of conduct we need more
of.
Right.
Especially now like thoughtful,
but guys that are really saying
something like being,
you know,
I'm getting back in,
so maybe I'll find them all like,
well,
you can't help but reckoned with
Chappelle.
I mean the demand is,
you know,
he's also arguably the best living stand
up and remind you of Richard was at that
time,
the best living standup might be still.
I'm lenny.
Bruce was decomposed by being arrested
by not being allowed to have freedom of
speech.
George Carlin took it to another level
where he said,
I'm cutting my hair no more and I'm
going to let myself say the things that
are on my mind and was a lot of anger
and a lot of prophecy and people.
My Mother didn't like him because he was
unkempt.
Yeah.
She wanted to kempt person.
She would have loved you very much.
Yeah.
I don't know if every camp I'm very.
It's a lot of hairspray and she wasn't.
She's so smart and he's handsome.
Outright Zagat enough to tell you what
my mother would say.
Carlin having that moment.
That's like you putting down the guitar.
Right.
That's why I think it's.
I think it's interesting when either get
good or not.
It's when you make that move you like,
you like learn something and then you
kind of start all over again because you
get the,
you get some chops,
you figure out what it's like to be in
front of people.
Um,
and then it's not an effort.
It's a pleasure.
Yeah.
I,
um,
I'm going to be 62 in May,
which is crazy.
So if you could delay this,
that would be great.
It's not letting that happen yet,
but I'm able to go on stage and I had a
gift.
Now having a special just done that.
I'm very proud of this.
Zero to 60,
which is from zero to being 60th.
Brilliant title wordy.
And it's on Amazon prime.
So my joke is he was a joke with it.
With two clicks you can buy the lotion
to watch the special inferring that
that's how aroused you'll get watching
my special can,
you know,
I retweeted your special the other day
and then I think you deleted the tweet
and I thought,
what,
what happened here?
Did you make a mistake in your tweet?
I did,
I made a mistake in my tweet and then I
was like,
oh,
well we do it again.
Let's see how the rest of this goes.
Okay.
I know,
I understand if you don't want to.
So let's not get ahead of those.
I'll show myself out.
Uh,
but.
But I,
um,
yeah,
I,
I put something wrong on there because
it's,
it's on many mediums.
It's not,
it's not a Netflix special,
but it's on every platform.
So it's on a spectrum.
DIRECTV,
Google.
So it's never been done like this till
now where they put it on every,
on demand.
So it's like you can choose between
wonder woman or zero to 60.
Hmm.
Let me think.
I'd much rather watch Bob than wonder
woman.
That's pretty cool though that because
right.
We all,
in the old days,
everyone just wanted the HBO special.
I mean,
I remember the day I started standing
up,
I was like,
I'm going to have an hbs.
I wanted one of my God.
Now you can have all sorts of other
things.
There's many different ways.
And,
and Netflix is kind of the jewel in the
crown.
So it was hbo,
but they mostly have a few new people,
but mostly they're regular team members
know bill or George Lopez of course,
who is just wonderful.
I just like George.
But um,
this has been a really cool model.
I'm being on Amazon.
Prime is actually in the world,
has it.
I just wanted it to be seen by as many
people.
That's how I stumbled about this thing.
Let's just get it out.
This,
this is seen by everybody I would think.
Right?
As long as youtube.
Let's get to the feed and Youtube and
now.
So every person that subscribes,
you make money.
No.
You do make money is they roll ads on
this.
We make money.
But you made a roll ads on this.
It depends on what we talk about.
Say you may be deemed too controversial
too.
I'm not controversial on fuller house.
That's on Netflix is a very family
oriented show.
What do you need to sell?
What product but help you make money on
this.
Will you know,
whatever they want to lay in before
this.
I don't care what they put in before.
That's the funny thing.
No one associates the ad with the
content,
you know,
so they just want me not to say anything
offensive so that the advertiser won't
say,
okay,
say I get talked about whatever,
like a fabric softener because any one
of those sheets,
that's like a good thing.
I would love that fabric.
I like fabric soft.
It's great stuff.
We did in and said to me what a bounce
you have on your jacket when it was
perfect,
perfect outfit and we compliment each
other.
I feel good about this.
I think it's.
I think we're crushing.
This is full house thing.
Hit it.
Had not heard of it until I did a little
research for this.
Right?
Apparently it was a big sitcom.
Yes it was.
It was for eight years and I didn't know
either.
I just knew I had a place to go to work
and that I would paid for kids private
school.
So I told you this when,
when we had dinner a couple weeks ago,
but my sister was,
she's nine years younger than me.
She was so,
and I know you hear this all the time,
but she was so obsessed with that show
that we were never allowed to watch TV
at dinner.
My family,
that was it.
We would sit and,
and have a good time or a bad time or
argue or laughed or whatever,
but my sister at some point took control
of the family and suddenly full house
was being watched during dinner.
Right.
She loves stamos.
Everyone loves statement.
Yeah,
that's true.
Everyone loves statement.
No.
Tell me a little bit about getting in on
that and how that differed from standup
and then suddenly even though you had
studied acting and all that,
but just like doing something that was
so different.
Completely different.
Um,
I'd always wanted to be on a sitcom.
I'd been around them,
you know,
I'd,
as I said,
I was a warmup bosom buddies or go visit
Robin doing mork and Mindy.
I would sneak into happy days.
I snuck into the Bob Newhart show.
I was under age.
It had to be 16 or 17.
I snuck into Mary Tyler Moore.
I would watch them filming these shows.
James l Dot Brooks,
uh,
producing Mary Tyler Moore show,
unbelievable.
And I saw Bob Newhart last night,
had the name drop once to know when we
can go to dinner,
didn't mention you as don rickles,
that,
that is a direct lift of the kind of
thing he would say.
I mean,
that's perfection that really is kind of
very professional.
He would say something like somebody
very famous,
you know,
I saw someone last night,
I saw,
I saw Chris rock last night,
didn't mention to you,
just so you know,
they could make it now just because of
the way we are about.
He was making it in an,
as a,
as a new young comedian.
Impossible.
Um,
but there's a new way to do it,
which is a way of love.
And some people do it.
So people will make fun of everyone.
My friend Jeff Ross is the postmaster
general,
um,
you know,
there,
there are ways to bash people,
but it's turned mean.
And what happened is,
and this is an understatement,
you know,
the roast.
I was roasted on comedy central,
but I had John Stamos was the roast
master.
I had all my friends were there,
I got to pick who was on it.
Most people don't.
You know,
Justin Bieber Roast,
no one knows him.
Most of the people and people think
roasting people is supposed to be mean
and it's a it.
If it doesn't come out of kindness and
love of the person or just blind,
I'm going to attack them,
but there's no attachment of anger to
this.
It's just evil.
It's just wrong.
And we're in a society where people
will,
they'll hit you back on a tweet,
they'll watch something,
you will see people on the news,
you'll listen to political leaders talk,
you'll hear people bash each other back
and forth,
and it comes from Don rickles thinking
that that's what he did.
That's not what the man did.
The man would,
would just,
you know,
see a man and a woman in the audience
and say,
is this your wife?
And the guy would go yes and dom and go,
Whoa,
whoa.
And that's just a but and his age has
something to do with it,
but also his tenacity and his.
And he started in the lounge two in the
morning,
doing three shows til five in the
morning and talk about the trenches and
all love.
So if someone comes out and makes fun of
people and does it out of love or does
it at a truth,
that's the safest way we're at right
now.
That's where the Chappelle thing comes
through.
That's where you look at certain people.
I really enjoy Mark Marin a lot.
And um,
Bill Burr,
um,
I mean there's so many people that are
so good,
um,
that,
that some people don't even know about
that sell out places constantly that are
just like Brian Regan and it's just,
he's so.
He's brilliant.
I mean,
he cares three,
two hours.
It was like,
what?
And it's clean.
Or you go see Seinfeld do what he does
and you go,
that's why he's Jerry side because it's
not just words Smith,
he's connected to everything he did.
It might be word for word in some ways,
but another night.
But my God,
it's fun and you know,
and then I'll,
you know,
I love anybody who is funny who just is
there to entertain people and it's not
only about them,
which is hard because we're a very
narcissistic group.
Right.
I mean comics are particularly,
there's a certain breed of craziness,
right.
That comes to comedy.
The best line I ever heard about that
was,
I've mentioned this a few times,
George Carlin on the view once and he's
sitting there with all the women around
him and he's talking about,
you know,
he was given,
he was,
he was selling or they had just come out
with like this anthology.
So that's what he was there for.
But he said something about how to be a
good comic you have to have a ton of
shit.
Like you have to have all this pain and
all this angst and all this stuff.
But then at some point you got to
conquer it because otherwise it will
conquer you.
And that's why so many comics die of
drug overdoses and all this other stuff.
Yeah.
But if you can own it,
then you could be 62.
And
why are you doing?
I don't know if I'm made doing standup
at nine,
but I'll be doing forms of it.
You couldn't stop even if you wanted to
write.
I could not stop working.
I,
I just directed this movie,
Benjamin,
which I'll talk about at length in the
third hour,
our interview.
But,
but I have to leave after hour or two.
But you're welcome to.
I'm going to stay.
We're just going to keep going.
It's just gonna be me and the camera.
But,
but I,
I love working without it.
I,
I'm an artist.
Uh,
and it sounds so fruity.
Pebbles to say that,
but I just am and I always will be and
I'll be making whether it be directing
or writing or performing.
I love acting.
There's no limit as long as you can
stand and walk and bend and remember
things,
you know,
it,
not fall into an open trunk.
The memory one goes first because now
there's guys on Broadway,
they're using ips.
I was going to say id ib is going to
look at the intercontinental missiles.
Yeah.
Not those.
No,
no.
That has been known and I hopefully will
live long enough that had 92 years old.
I'll be on Broadway and I'll have an
earwig in and they'll feed me the lines
and I don't care if I'm good,
if it's done right.
I saw Peter O'toole and Amanda plummer
and my Fair Lady,
the most miscast version of my fair lady
on Broadway.
And I think he had a thing in his ear.
He was no child when he did it.
Playing that character is very
fascinating because my fair lady,
which is a play,
I don't know if people are familiar,
but um,
sometimes the audience could use a
little tiny bit older,
but it's not a millennial's favorite,
but you know,
she is pygmalion,
which of course loses more people.
Gen x doesn't even follow pygmalion,
but it,
what's amazing about it is he's 40 years
older than her.
Uh,
no matter how you play that play.
Yeah.
That is a musical.
Was Rex Harrison and Audrey Hepburn.
He's 40 years older than her.
He is maybe 50,
but he's 60 and she's 20 and that's that
and he's trying to make her a classy
woman.
The chauvinistically misogynistic,
unacceptable way.
And it is one of the best musicals ever
written for people that don't know.
That was the original premise of.
Or that was the original inspiration of
pretty woman.
Right,
right.
That is true.
I'm not making that up.
No,
you're not.
you're not usually trying to make it
honest woman out of,
uh,
an honest hooker.
Yeah.
Alright.
Let's talk about this whole house thing.
So that right from honest hooker.
Hooker's you did it.
I was going to let you drop one of the
girls names,
but.
Okay.
So.
All right.
So then you'd suddenly,
you're on television.
Everyone knows who you are,
what a lot of money is such a good edit
point.
No,
we don't.
I've got offered the job.
Yeah.
Uh,
I was fired from a morning program on
CBS,
which was against Good Morning America
today show for being too hot for morning
TV.
They had another actor play the
character of Danny Tanner.
Um,
I always feel bad about that.
The pilot we shot with the pilot we shot
with someone else makes me sad,
but the same producers and other people
in this business have done that before
with many,
many shows.
Robin Williams was not the first work to
perfect strangers.
Was was not a Mark Lynn Baker.
It was,
there was a gay housekeeper in the pilot
episode of the Golden Girls.
That guy got the boot I,
but that's what I played on full house
anyway.
But I ended up with the part because I
was fired and they made it available for
me.
And I'm Jeff Franklin.
The exec producer wanted me originally
for it and Bob boy yet.
And Tom Miller who still produced fuller
house.
Um,
it's a complicated thing.
Show business.
It is so complicated.
All you want to do is entertain a bunch
of people.
And then all of this stuff happens.
And I played a character because I want
it to be on three men and a baby had
just come out.
And we were talking about that before we
were rolling on this.
Fantastic show is we saw the Gutenberg a
dinner that night out of.
We did see the Gutenberg and he brings
his Bible and he went over almost.
He had to,
he had the fish and he had enough for
everyone and the water.
Guess what it turned it to.
Anyway,
I'm sorry.
So this,
this part was something that I wanted in
three men and a baby with Steven and Ted
Danson and um,
uh,
yeah,
I had just come out and so we were that
we were Dave and John David again.
John Demos were already diapering Ashley
and Mary Kate and I was not in those
scenes.
So they reshot the pilot and all of a
sudden the show ABC fought to keep it
on.
Doesn't happen like that anymore.
They,
they put it on twice a week.
It ran on Tuesdays,
didn't run on Fridays and then they
started to run it twice a week for
awhile and then they ordered more
episodes and it wasn't doing very well,
but they believed in it and we were on
against Seinfeld,
which also wasn't doing very well.
Right.
That.
So that's around what,
like 89 90 now at 87.
80 eight.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
So then 89 is yes,
we're not doing well.
And then after four years we started to
do well,
we switched studios from Sony because I
know people want to give their
demographics right on Google maps to
warner brothers to be on the same stage
exactly where fuller house has done now.
That's ended the last four years there.
And then it was a really big hit.
And of course with network television,
if you look at ratings now you go,
my God,
how could they cancel it with that
chair?
Insane.
And then we were offered to go to the CW
or the web.
I can't remember what it was first
because it's all a blur.
We were offered one more year to go
there and we just Kinda said John and I,
I kinda,
I thought we did it,
you know,
we kinda got canceled.
So why do we want to beg to go somewhere
else?
And they do that.
Sometimes they say columns and it never
works,
right?
No,
you're somewhere else.
And then people find it.
Would they do it for is for syndication.
So.
Oh,
what years is that from?
Everything looks different,
it looks smaller,
but it was the secret to that show was
that there was actual affection between
the cast and uh,
and in good writing and good morals,
things where kids could watch your
sister could watch it and feel good
afterwards because they had my sister,
Tanya,
a,
you were great in rocky and that's
right.
That's right.
There you go.
And it just,
I,
your brother loves you very,
very much and,
and really appreciate that you would
make them all watch full house instead
of having Nice,
nice dinner.
In fact,
he'd make the dinner nights here.
All right,
let's do just a little bit more on TV
and then I want to talk politics with
you and just sort of,
you're a philosophical guy.
I am a philosophical guide.
It gets me in trouble sometimes.
So you do fuller house.
Yes.
Big Star.
Then you're also doing America's
funniest home videos.
Another thing where it's a blooper show
and I'm playing on Sunday night,
seven to 8:00
at night.
People were in church that day,
so then that night I'm hosting a show
that has to be done very palatable for
America and the world was number one in
China.
Where was that hard for you because you.
I mean,
you really had to.
That was,
that was.
That had to.
It was a little difficult and it was a
gift horse so the tree opens up,
you know,
it's the number one show,
the producer of into bona called me one
day on my curly cord carphone and said,
we're number one,
and I said,
you mean PP anyway?
No.
I said,
we're,
we're number one show on television.
It was a phenomenon and the joke is if
you wanted to see a man get hit in the
nuts,
you had to come through me.
I was the gatekeeper but in a funny way
and now it's all this I.
Youtube will give you anything you want.
That's exactly what I was going to say.
That somehow all of the stuff that
people click that's just quick and you
watch someone get smashed with saying or
he was sending her fault.
It was all born out of people walking
around with cam quarters just because
you guys were like,
well,
let's do it.
He had the savvy,
uh,
it was a famous show.
It came out of a show in Japan,
which I think are still partners with
it.
I don't know the business dealings,
but I'm going to look it up.
Give me a minute.
Let me just get on my phone.
Yeah,
yeah,
no,
I'll do it right here.
But,
uh,
it became a,
a phenomenon because they took a,
did it amazing.
They did the grassroots approach,
which we don't see anywhere.
They asked in people magazine.
They took out an ad.
We have a new show called America's
funniest home videos,
full-page people magazine.
I'm send your vhs tapes and you could be
on television and you could win prize
money.
God,
it sounds like.
And that is how they got the first hour
of tapes.
And what happened to me was I was doing
a year of full house.
I get this tape.
They said this is an amicable,
a young man.
The man that now is,
is Walt Disney,
is Bob Iger.
He is ABC.
He wanted me for it.
Ted Harbert was at the network,
wanted me for it.
I'm from full house.
I seemed like a very amicable guy.
They'd seen my standup.
They didn't care.
They didn't know it was like,
it wasn't as a bluish as I became,
as I got more free with myself.
I was going to ask you about that.
It wasn't,
I didn't draw as many f bombs,
it just,
but it was all weird.
It all had things that you can't say.
So what was that like for you?
Because he was still there.
I mean obviously I'm not telling you
anything you to know,
but like he was so sacral and the jokes
you'd have to make and I,
and I'm proud of them.
Yeah,
I wrote it with two.
Uh,
the jokes were to Canadian guys,
so there was an 18 percent exchange rate
on the humor,
but it was todd.
Thanks brother.
May he rest in peace?
No,
his brothers a lot.
I'm Todd Thicke,
uh,
analytics brother and uh,
Bob are not as a writer from the
smothers brothers show.
And we wrote all the jokes,
we wrote 55 pages a week.
I would do the voiceovers look out.
Oh,
look at me,
you know,
just bad mel blanc,
who was warner brothers,
bugs bunny.
That I have to explain it to the
millennials.
Millennial who's bugs bunny thing after
this?
Okay.
It was bugs bunny.
But who is Marvin the Martian?
You made me so mad.
It was Marvin the Martian.
I'm not a good impression.
But,
um,
it was a big production to.
I wanted it to be a variety show,
so we would have big guests on.
We'd have on a Rodney Dangerfield,
anybody that was a friend of mine,
we'd had Leslie Nielsen on Jonathan
Winters,
full house,
you know,
we'd have and it was an hour and,
and it is still on to this day,
a testament to Vin and to the people
that make that show,
you know,
it went to Tom Bergeron,
went through many people that went to
Richard kind hosted at wants,
daisy frontage,
John Fugelsang.
And um,
there was no way to stop it because it
was a guaranteed laugh.
And what I didn't like,
what would bother me is if a guy falls
in a manhole and then you see somebody
in the audience to other head back
laughing,
but you never see him climb out of the
manhole on like,
is he dead?
You know?
So I hadn't done a charity for people's
nuts.
Like with Bob Saget charity for a great
idea.
Something.
Yeah.
Agates Sag.
It's agates something that would have.
Yeah.
Because there should have been people.
There were a lot of not hits and it was
all the good ones were when it was a six
year old taking a baseball bat and his
chest just jab and his dad.
Even just before this I was,
I just quickly put Americans money
selling videos in the youtube search and
it's just not hit after hit.
There's one that's like 600 hits in a
row.
I mean they just cut him real quick
because one thing that got to me was
someone had sent me a clip reel that I
think they aired on the show,
which was old people falling.
And I had,
when I was like,
I'm glad I'm not there because that was,
that was the only time I went,
like,
oh,
come on.
And they're falling on cement and stuff,
which sounds funny to Bros in a bar
drinking beers.
But if you'll watch it,
it's kind of snuff fish.
But uh,
as long as I know everybody's okay.
I didn't want to be a where people
filmed themselves hurting their friends.
So I felt like I was hurting before.
But that didn't matter.
I,
I enjoyed for those first few years of
doing it.
I just,
I loved the hell out of it.
I mean everybody was talking about it
and loving it.
I had friends calling me going,
what is this?
Because no one had seen it before.
But it's interesting because it's like
kind of one of those things that we
don't have anymore.
Like we don't have shows being right.
There are things like,
yes,
everyone watches game of thrones,
you're,
everyone watches this or that on
Netflix.
But we don't have like sort of
mainstream like decent things that
families can watch anymore.
And they know and they put all the
nonsense aside,
you know,
and that's what I want to do.
That's kind of.
And um,
I'm in,
I'm in talks about a couple of different
things.
I want to do something,
a variety.
I don't know what it is.
You know,
I,
I love directing,
so I just did this movie so we knock on
wood people,
go see this movie,
Benjamin,
which we will,
we'll get to it for a second.
Let's get to it right now if you want.
I feel that that was the right way,
but I will give closure to that last
thing.
Just saying that I do feel that there
would be,
it would be wonderful to have a family
sit down on a Sunday night.
I mean wonderful world of Disney used to
be on at 7:00
or 7:30
when I was a kid on NBC and you turn it
on now and it's just another one of
those people punching each other in,
in big sumo wrestler costumes.
And that's not what I want to see with
my family.
I want to say it,
but that's the cheap replacement.
And that's variety,
that's reality variety,
but real variety is we're going to
entertain you and we're going to bring
on guests and it's going to be fun.
I mean,
I guess snl is the closest thing to
have.
Yeah.
But that's not really.
It wouldn't play in prime time.
But you want something,
you're talking,
you want something that's funny,
but also you can do some serious stuff.
You want to staying relevant.
I mean,
it's,
you want.
I can have everything,
but I think it needs to make people
laugh the most and then it can have its,
its waves in it.
And so I will be taking pitches right
after this.
All right,
let's talk.
Benjamin and Benjamin.
Benjamin comes out in the summer.
It is a movie that I spent seven years
on.
It is an independent movie.
I'm very low budget.
I'm just getting hit in the nuts.
Uh,
no one knowing that there is a fight in
it.
Um,
at least I can't even.
I can't tell you who me and Dave Foley
won't talk.
I don't want.
No,
no.
Spoiler alerts.
Uh,
it's about,
it's really about a dysfunctional
family,
which is most families and we believe
that I directed it and I acted in it
with some amazing people that are name
really quickly,
which are rob corddry,
who's hilarious.
Kevin Pollak,
Cherio,
Terry,
Dave Foley,
Max burkholder plays my son.
He was on parenthood.
We think that he is on crystal meth.
So it's a dark comedy.
I thought you meant the actor.
No movies about movies,
about plays.
Benjamin,
we believe all the actors.
I don't know what you're doing
in the movie.
You were on crystal meth during the
making of the.
In order to be able to survive working
with me because I was out of my mind
because we had a 15 day shoot.
It was a low,
low budget.
Yeah,
I know this show has longer to shoot my
movie and I'm so my,
in the movie,
my son Benjamin we believe is on crystal
meth.
And so Mary Lynn Rice cub plays my
girlfriend.
She's from 24,
very good comedian actress and she posts
on facebook that we need an intervention
for the boy.
And that's not where you post an
intervention.
People don't post interventions on
facebook.
It's supposed to be kind of quiet and
done properly.
Maybe a note posted.
And uh,
so rob corddry is our family
gynecologist.
He leaves the intervention and Kevin
Pollak plays my brother and Peri Gilpin
Santa and Clara Mamet.
GotTa have a Mamet.
Uh,
she's so good at it and I'm,
uh,
David Ho and uh,
Johnny Western and uh,
it's just,
it's an ensemble and it takes place in
one night and it's just basically the
one line would be on it that the people,
the person you think has the problem.
It's the people.
And I can't really give much more
family.
The family,
your family is the woman,
the problem,
you know,
people.
So many write a one line for this movie
quick.
Yeah,
we need it for the one sheet.
But the people that you think have the
problem,
the people that are accusing someone of
having the problem are the ones with the
problem.
Oh,
that's a spoiler alert.
That's a little bit of a spoiler.
But I feel like that transcends this
movie.
That's just a general thing,
serious movie with,
uh,
with a,
with a comedy bent to it and I,
and I'm very proud of it and so thank
you for letting me plug all of that.
Alright.
Saget,
we did career.
That was it.
That my career is just beginning.
We Ngo or career ended my career
completely.
It ended.
We never got past fuller house.
It's over.
No,
we did.
Benjamin were good.
We did Benjamin.
We know we got,
we got other stuff coming.
Yeah.
We didn't even talk about a half baked,
but we'll just,
we'll just say that it never actually
did that in real life.
My real.
I got it.
Okay.
Um,
all right.
Let's talk.
I just want to talk about politics and
just kind of what you think is going on
in the world because if that's what you
do here,
that is what I do here.
But even though I only know you a little
bit from the conversation we had at
dinner,
I got just got a sense that like you
actually,
you're obviously very sensitive.
Like that's pretty clear.
I'm overly sensitive or you strike me as
like a good liberal,
like you want people to be treated well
as fair.
I think of myself as a liberal.
I must be.
Well,
what do I look good?
Myself as a humanist,
I was on a plane the other day which no
comedians ever said,
and transducers,
that gentleman was on the plane and he
had a and he was about 60 years old and
he seemed like a successful businessman
of some kind.
And I was in the first class section
because there was a cat back in coach.
It was a cat for a case.
You get sick.
She had her
security animal to keep her.
What do you call those animals?
The,
a special animal if special needs or
whatever.
But I'm deathly allergic.
So I was upfront and allergic to cats
too.
Think so I was saying to this gentleman
and he had on big bright Red America
first shirt.
And so if I was uh,
I guess,
uh,
what your brand is a liberal,
I guess that shirt would bother me.
But I just looked at the guy and he
seemed like a nice guy.
I didn't.
I just said,
do you have an allergy to cats?
He went,
no.
My wife's got a cat.
I said,
so you have a category?
No,
my wife has a cat and we laughed a
little bit.
And what it said on his shirt,
on his shirt is a shirt I would wear.
It's not a where I'm at.
I mean,
I do believe a tube.
I love America.
I believe that where you live,
you want to put first,
you want to take care of your people,
you want to take care of your hometown.
Oh,
you're coming out with that far right
craziness.
Or you want to take care of your
country.
But,
um,
down,
down.
But I don't,
but I'm not.
If you're,
if you're kind and you're not out doing
some closet hatred,
uh,
or blatant hatred,
I don't know.
But I,
I just look at my dad's whole thing was
be kind to people.
So it sounds like a pacifist and might
bother people,
but that's what we're supposed to do.
Yeah.
Is the problem with that,
that you just get nipped off by both
sides?
I mean,
I see that a lot now that I do think
there's this interesting center
developing.
I don't even know why there's sides.
Of course.
Yeah,
of course I do.
But you know,
and,
and people go,
well,
you're a democrat.
Right?
And I'm like,
I'll vote for anybody that can get us
out of this mess.
You know,
I'd,
I'd bring my dad back from the grave and
vote for him.
He'd be such a good candidate.
A grateful dead video.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Are you,
would you consider yourself a liberal?
Is that where you are?
Yeah.
I still consider myself a liberal,
but most of the liberal things that I
believe in,
I can pretty much explain from a
libertarian perspective at this point
and that I just don't want the
government involved in my life.
That's it.
And I think you should live your life
however you see fit and I'll live mine
however I see fit and like you have a
lot more money than me,
right?
Fair to say.
I don't know,
but we're going to do spreadsheet exams
right after this is over.
Let's be clear.
I'm on Youtube.
You've been on network television.
You've got three chickens outside.
I don't have three chickens.
I don't know their value,
but you could have chickens.
The point is I don't any of your stuff
just because you make more money than
me.
Right.
I can't have any of your money.
It would be nice I suppose,
but I don't deserve any of that.
That's what taxes are about and that's
where our are incredibly rich society
and are incredibly poor society are at
odds with each other and that has been
since the beginning of time since you
know castles were built with a dictator
in a king living in it and everybody had
to go build all this stuff and they were
slaves.
So I mean it's it,
it does.
The metaphor doesn't change.
The representation doesn't change that
the downtrodden or downtrodden and are
disgruntled and then other people are
angry at things that they should just
take a frikken chill pill over.
Yeah.
Well that constant outreach thing.
Well,
there's a lot to be outraged over also
because how do they all have the,
the,
the problem with,
you know,
wanting to entertain people with wanting
to be a comedian is,
it's nearly impossible when there's so
many deaths when there's so many tragic
things happening,
which there always have been,
but we are at a news ratio where it's
coming at us.
You just,
you know,
you hit your computer on and it says,
news alert and you hit news alert and
you're like,
you're afraid to hit the button.
You're afraid to get up in the Morton
and hit whatever new service you go.
So that's just a matter of us knowing
about it more because I have steven
pinker on next week who's a harvard
psychologist who,
and his whole argument is actually that
things are better than they've ever been
using empirical scientific evidence
about the amount of people that are
being exposed quicker because we
actually have more people out of poverty
now worldwide than ever before.
More people with drinkable water than
ever before.
More people that leave the environment,
uh,
enlightenment values and every port.
But we
why more people would drinkable water.
Yeah.
More the around the world.
Know around the world more now than ever
before.
But that might be true.
Is that,
are we a hundred percent?
That's true.
I'm pretty sure that's true.
But what about,
what about more people being murdered?
What about the safety of our kids?
What about,
you know,
all these things over,
but most of those,
most of those markers actually,
they're better than ever before.
It's just that we hear about them all
the time now and we obsess over it.
Not that we obsess over the negative.
Yeah,
because we're not presented the positive
and if we're presented the positive,
it's through a skewed broadcast.
It's,
it's,
it's not really presented by someone
that comfort to you.
The show comforts you more than most
shows because of the way you handle it.
That's just a fact.
If you're trying to have watched you
several times,
you're trying to put two factions
together that might have similar or
report pose views,
discussing opposed views and are saying,
why can't it be like this?
Because if you try to go toward an
idealistic goal,
the dream of it is how you can almost
get there.
That's,
that's how the country was founded.
Besides,
you know,
taking a lot of things away from the
people that lived here.
That's a whole other show.
But you've got three Cox in your yard.
Pretty good.
So I just trying to get you out of this
now.
I'm not really politically astute but
did I make any sense?
Yeah.
Well you aren't making some sense,
but I think you actually articulated
that.
I mean you're around tomorrow at the
time.
That must be a.
I saw just last night and he said Aloha
because we were in Hawaii together.
But I do say that I'd rather get my news
from,
you know,
from John Oliver and,
and Bill Maher and Stephen Colbert and
Seth Meyers and Jimmy Kimmel than the
newscasters.
What does that tell you about US media?
We need a relief and so the news itself
is already a parody and it's also so
obsessive no matter where it's coming
from.
And we're also dealing with a regime
which flip flops in the media and on
twitter faster than I've ever exist
because we never had a president tweet
us,
you know,
we did.
I mean,
Obama did,
but it wasn't.
It wasn't like,
I hate this.
I love this,
you know,
18,
21,
18.
It's like you're in Vegas,
you know,
just double down.
Um,
do you see him as the problem though?
Or is a symptom because I really see the
symptom.
It's a symptom.
It was,
it was voting for a guy that was on a
show that said,
you're fired.
So what do you expect to get?
Um,
you know,
if you're gonna,
if you're going to get the host of
America's got talent,
you're going to get the most out of
people.
This is going to be the best a
procession ever.
It's going to be dancers and singers.
And Yeah,
if you had been the president,
people would be getting be at a Dick,
jokes you,
you would from me.
I guarantee you a dick joke a day.
And I would treat them and not three in
the morning.
I do not tweet,
well,
three in the morning,
no one should note,
well no one except the president
because,
but I,
but I just think you know,
what did we expect?
But I think a lot of people were
surprised and I think it doesn't matter.
It's happening and this is it and so we
want to better humanity and there are
great people in the world and there are
great people in other countries leading
the world the best they can and there's
a lot of slackers and there's other
people that are just part of the
political bunch of crap,
but they're still great people and
there's great people watching this.
There's nice people watching your show.
Yeah,
you're a nice person.
Nice people.
You don't.
I don't think you get a lot of haters.
Do you get a ridiculous amount of haters
do.
Yeah,
because I talk about the problems that I
see with the modern day left and the
liberals and they don't like someone to
address those things.
That was once one of them by fake
manner.
Why can't I know they,
they don't fall.
Don't fall for that.
Perfect shrink.
You could,
you could calm me down through tightrope
walking.
That was because we slipped a little
saying in your water.
There is something in my water.
I'm feeling different.
You notice the tone has changed.
I'm not leaving them on the show
tomorrow.
Otherwise vibrating it.
Oh yeah.
Though.
I bet things moved in.
Yeah.
Is there anyone that chart behind you?
You know,
that it's just Los Angeles,
but it's an eye chart.
Pretty clever.
Huh?
That's really it.
We call that art.
Get well done.
Mr.
Bond.
Pretty good.
Uh,
is there anyone that you're paying
attention to these days that you think
is making some sense?
Because I appreciate all the comments
but the compliments,
but like that's what I think I'm doing
here is just trying to make a little
census of things.
To be honest,
John Oliver has been,
um,
I can't think of anyone political that
has made me go,
oh,
there's a great hope there.
Um,
and I'm interested in something.
Some people have to say that seemed wow
that was noble,
but they're not going to do anything
about it or they're not going to run or.
But I'd like to think there's so many
out there,
you know,
I'd like to think you think that's part
of it,
that we all talk a lot,
but we don't.
Do I sense that sort of what's happening
here?
So is that everyone's saying shit,
we're fighting always just a bunch of
fucking voices.
It's frequencies everywhere.
All through our heads.
It's just noise.
So trump was like,
all right,
I'm going to do it.
None of you do anything.
And trump's like,
all right,
I'll do it.
I'll run for president.
You Morons.
And guess what?
He was right?
Yeah.
And the way he does it,
he can turn anything.
He wants to do a rally.
If he feels the moment and he gets the
right South Park background behind it,
but he's doing it and I don't know,
I just don't know anything.
It's too.
You can't predict a thing.
And we want that security is feeling
secure that you know at least what
tomorrow brings.
We don't know what an hour from now
brings.
We have never been on our haunches more
not knowing what's gonna come out of
him,
out of the White House.
Who's going to get fired,
but that's not the issue.
The issue is where's the world at and
where's our kids at and where are the
things that really matter.
What really matters is people.
This is sort of like you're giving me
the ending of a full house episode and
you want to tell you something else.
I don't want you drinking beer at the
prompt and you cannot have a horse in
the living room.
This is where the synthesizer music.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and you know what?
Always follow your gut because your gut
is not wrong.
If you feel it deep inside,
then take imodium because any moment
there could be a release.
I wish I could have done full house like
that.
That would have been nice.
Just full of diarrhea and give you a
chance for bloopers like that where you
could just.
Oh,
there.
Bloopers grills that were that.
I said horrific things.
Yeah,
there's is.
I wrote a book called dirty daddy and I
told.
I talked about something I did on the
set once and I got in a lot of trouble,
but I won't say what it is because it's
not repeatable on this youtube channel,
but it is in that book and it was
something I should not have done,
uh,
with a,
um,
well I can't,
I can't say it,
but it was something that happened
because we have been.
Okay.
I did something that we,
we had stand ins for the kids that were
mannequins and I was alone on the set
with just the crew and the monitors were
on and I didn't know that.
Not acceptable under these conditions or
under this time.
Do you ever worry about that?
Because you still know because
everything I've done is when someone
goes,
oh,
someone's going to come forward wind.
When's you're being bad thing going to
come out.
I don't know.
Look at my last special.
You want it?
It's right there.
You know,
weird way.
That's like your.
It's like your saving grace sort of like
you.
I am a confessional.
Yeah,
I mean I,
there's a story in there in the,
in zero to 60 does special where I say I
was given ludes by a club owner which
were serious drug.
It was almost like a roofie terrible
drug from wolf of Wall Street,
Jonah Hill and Leo Dicaprio and I'm a
club owner,
told me to give it to a waitress and I
could have my way with her and I instead
to cut to the chase and ruin a joke.
I actually took it myself to knock
myself out,
so because she was kind of hitting on me
because I did it too because that's kind
of guy and so all my stuff's out there
because I didn't,
I didn't do anything a diabolical that I
can recall that roofing yourself,
can you?
Yes.
Yeah.
Can you,
can you add that?
I can recall to every single thing I
said on this entire interview,
that's what politicians do.
Okay.
So I'm going to come in and I'm going to
voice over this new tire interview just
so that I can recall.
Yeah,
I feel we should end this either with
something hitting you in the nuts or
something or a song.
Oh yes,
we could do a song,
but you already gave me the nice full
house ending.
What do you think is the you.
You were the one here with the brain.
Tell me what you think is the hope of
how we can get hope is is communication.
Yeah.
That this is happening now that people
are doing this,
that you know what I mean?
Your discourse,
your fiance Kelly came across me.
We traded a couple messages on twitter.
I was like,
oh.
She gets it like she's to find some
answers.
I'm trying to find some answers and we
went out for dinner.
We all became friends immediately and
that people and that whatever the
differences that we may have where you
know,
you're probably still a little more left
than I am on some things and just
doesn't even matter.
I,
I think on some things probably you're,
you're probably a little more,
Eh,
I don't know.
It doesn't need to.
It's irrelevant.
I dress left.
I don't know.
The accounts just doesn't even matter,
but the point is that the reason that
shows like this are working is because
of this,
that you were willing to come here,
sit down to come here.
Yeah.
You immediately said to me that you
wanted to come,
but that's the point.
It's like people want this now they they
are so tired of the other thing and all
we're doing is exactly what Tom Snyder
did and he was just talking to a camera,
but what were what cars.
He had a guest or William f Buckley or
any of these people who said,
let's try to find some answers and you
can get,
I think as many answers from Bob Saget
as you can from the guys.
I think you get far more answers from
listening to someone like you had some
life experience and that cares.
Then you can virtually listening to cnn
all day long.
Well you can get.
Well,
we never got into which we don't want to
get into,
which is all the depth that I had in my
family.
So much death of friends.
I just lost someone today.
I'm just talking about.
We can go there.
Well,
all I was going to say was that's what
centers everybody because it seems we
all go through our birth and death and
they all happen differently and when
they happen at an unfortunate age,
like our last two sisters at 34 and 47,
that's.
That's what centers you.
That's bigger than everything is the
loss of life and when people die,
when young people die,
there's nothing more.
That's all that matters.
Yeah,
it does.
The rest of it is your belief.
This is that this is that.
It's yes,
you want to solve in a civilization how
to keep people alive,
but the empathy is,
is what's missing and just quickly to
touch on what we didn't touch on,
but we talked about before the show
started.
Okay.
I'm going.
The talk shows that exist at night to
chat shows as they call them in England.
When I would do Johnny Carson Show and
before him was Jack Paar who I got to
meet and before him was Steve Allen who
I got to meet and these are guys that
they all had the tonight show those
gentlemen.
And then johnny ended up with it,
um,
that was viewed how they would tell
their guests,
you're coming to a cocktail party,
how do I dress like a cocktail party?
How do I talk?
You're at a cocktail party,
you're in Johnny's living room and he's
sharing that living room with everybody.
Well,
why does he have a desk in his living?
Because he wants a desk.
He wants a place for his ashtray.
Smokes.
Got a little.
Maybe he's got a drink there.
Whatever
that,
that they used to do that.
I mean,
there's a lot of white ones.
They're smoking,
they're drinking,
you know,
Burt Reynolds is.
I mean,
it's amazing.
And then talk about what we want.
We don't want to see it.
Although sometimes we do.
We see some strange things that happen.
I mean a lot of and certainly had some,
you know,
Joachim Phoenix moments,
those kind of things.
We're still going to see more stuff like
that.
People are going to do whatever trippy
stuff they're doing.
But the truth of it is those late night
shows are supposed to be entertainment.
That's what this post to be.
They've become a bit of let's attack
everything today that we've been through
because look what happened today because
it's been getting ratings and people
that necessarily might not do political
comedy like James Corden.
He's in entertainment oriented man.
He's been very talented men from
Broadway.
He's does at Carpool Karaoke.
He but he comes out and does a seven
minute monologue that might have a bunch
of stuff in it about the White House,
but that's not.
We're not born to do that,
but that's what's feeding the beast,
but it's supposed to be a time when you
chill at the end of the day where you're
entertain,
where you relax and when you want to get
that.
Tom Snyder,
when you want to get that,
dare I say the name in a sentence.
Charlie rose because that's what he did.
He did a one on one,
but when you say a name like that,
it can't help it cause someone to recoil
dot Larry King for my purposes.
Larry King,
I've known forever and I adore him.
He's a great guy.
Larry King.
I'm a post to have dinner with them.
Kelly and I are supposed to go ahead
with him and Shawna on for dinner.
We can go to that place if you invite
Sean,
that place that we went that place so we
would,
we don't talk about but a neat place.
He is quite a character.
He,
I went on Larry King Show,
he read my book and every time he sees
me he goes,
I loved your book second.
And I know I'm thinking it's because he,
he forgot that he keeps telling me,
but he's just,
I've just known him a long time and um,
and he,
he was very,
very good at it,
you know,
and we've got some really good people
doing the news.
So some real good people out there.
I mean,
Lorenzo Donald's,
a friend of mine,
I,
uh,
I like them a lot.
Um,
that name right there might flag people,
Msnbc and uh,
too many consonants.
We hate it,
but I don't know,
I just see we need to be entertained.
It's really complicated to do it at this
time in a way without bringing up human
issues,
moral issues.
And I'm going to do the best I can to do
that.
You know,
it's funny,
I remember,
so I was never,
even though I think you know him
personally,
I was never a fan of Leno on the tonight
show.
I loved cars and even though it was my
kind of very early years,
but Leno to me,
I always liked the bill Hicks thing or,
and you know,
they had that rival and I liked that
sort of more raw and gravity and Lenovo
to me was like he was just the corporate
version.
So I never liked it.
But in an odd way I suddenly had this
bizarre respect for him now.
Well he was,
he was a comedian hosting the tonight
show.
Yeah.
And I that he wasn't overtly political
all the time.
Now it's always political and I almost
missed that
in a way,
even though he wasn't really my guy in
terms of comedy.
But I know,
I know everyone says he's incredible
standup,
which has nothing to do with his great
standup.
And I was
in turn on the Mike Douglas show within
Philadelphia at 18 years old.
And I was on his very first television
appearance.
Wow.
So I know Jay that long.
And so there's a interesting history and
then,
you know,
Johnny Carson,
David Letterman,
Conan,
those were guys that I would go on those
shows and I felt the most connection.
But Jay,
I would go on and promote a movie I'd
worked on that I directed that I worked
so hard and he couldn't have been more
gracious,
you know.
So yeah,
I don't have to do chemo is one of the
sweetest people alive that does this,
you know?
Um,
and gold bears great.
I mean,
it's an interesting time for media and
for broadcasting.
I just want to see us get into some kind
of place of peace of mind in the world
and we're not there.
That's a big lift man.
I mean,
that's right.
Like that's why I'm doing this.
That's why you want to do this or I
never wanted to do.
So
I've never wanted to perform more.
I'm more motivated to go do standup.
I booked these Stena,
I'm on tour.
I'm trying to work out trying to come up
with new stuff because I know you do a
special on,
you deplete it,
but you know,
you don't want to just give them
something they just bought or heard,
but people really need it and I need to
do it because it takes people out of.
It brings them into their life.
You know,
you think like the last sense makers
these days.
There's a couple others that I think
there's a few.
There's a few comedians that I would
rather watch than almost anybody.
Um,
there are some good motivational
speakers.
There's some good good clergy out there.
I'm not a subscriber that much.
Um,
I'm a comedian so I kind of listened to
the people that have a lot to say and
some of them really do have a lot to
say.
So I respect.
I respect people with a point of view
that aren't malicious.
That would be you.
Did we do it all here?
I think pretty much.
Unless you want to.
You got to walk.
You want to make some vegetables,
have a great walk.
And I knew you had a walk me one
disaster story one,
like a nightmare I was telling you
before about my my thing when I was on
at the RNC convention and I was sweating
like crazy and Larry King said it's more
like,
like Albert Brooks in broadcast news.
I was on stage to take us out with a
disaster.
Say I get a disaster of standup,
but anything.
Give me some life.
Very well.
Thank you.
Give me a professional.
Not a life disaster.
I gave you a life disaster.
All right.
How about one life named her name?
Dropping like disaster.
I'm on on an
airplane on America on an a 7:47
A.
I'm on the video show is number one at
the time so you can then list famous
people on the plane in the newspaper by
WHO's the most famous and how they're
listed in the newspaper.
But I was on a plane with David Bowie
and Amman and Greg Kinnear and Richard
Lewis.
Or where was that?
This was an American flight out of JFK
to La.
That's hilarious.
And also mark mckeown who was on the CBS
morning news and a friend of mine,
um,
and so the plane starts taking off.
This would never exist today as we're
taking off in the air.
We hear an explosion and one of the
engines apparently blows out.
The plane goes,
rickety.
We then land at JFK.
So a very long time ago.
Um,
and we find out first they take the VIP,
which is people I named on two carts.
And Richard Lewis is yelling next to
David Bowie,
only a couple of us are Jews.
I'm like,
I'm not to this.
So now we're in the club and I'm getting
to talk to David Bowie.
So I'm going,
okay,
this was worth an explosion.
I'm fun.
And who could not have been more
gracious and um,
and it was just a,
it was dangerous and upsetting.
They two hours go by,
they put us back on the same plane,
turns out it was a fuel hose that came
loose,
which is just like turning a screw on a
gasket on your lawnmower.
And they fixed it,
which would never happen.
Now that would get you a new plane or
cancel you completely or whatever.
And uh,
we then took off and I made some joke,
I think the movie outbreak had just come
out and I said something like,
there was a monkey caught in the,
uh,
in the engine.
And then Richard Lewis yells out.
That's a good one.
Bob Amman is from Zaire.
And so I'm called out and then as we
take off,
Richard Lewis Yells,
thanks Bob to the whole plane and at
that time you could go into the cockpit
this pre nine slash 11.
And um,
I was able to ask the pilots what
happened.
So I actually told the VIP [inaudible]
no one else.
What happened?
Well,
you shouldn't,
they didn't tell the other people.
So that was a,
that's true disaster story.
I mean,
that could have ended incredibly badly
and I would have been fourth.
I would put him to settle that with
Louis because we could,
we could get him here and we can
moderate some discussion last night.
And he and I are gonna.
He holds me by the face and hugs me and
we're going to figure out the list,
but he's going to tell me that I would
have gone ahead of him simply because of
that dumb video show,
but he would say dumb video show in
order to do it because that was probably
1988,
89,
you know,
it's one of the,
one of the nicest moments I've had on
this when I had Richard Lewis and he
left and you know,
he's kind of a Germaphobe is Larry and
you know,
he doesn't shake hands.
He does this as he said goodbye to me.
I walked him out and when I opened up
the
door,
he just said,
he,
he said something like,
you're great,
and he touched me on the cheek and I was
like,
I like melted.
I was living.
Does this rabbinical thing?
Is that what?
That is?
Erotic rabbinical thing that I think he
learned from his shrink for a jury learn
differently shaped or the other story,
which is a very simple one,
very,
very short story.
I was in San Francisco performing
standup.
I learned that.
Be careful what you do,
messing with a heckler.
A guy who was about eight feet tall,
got up on stage and got me in a
headlock.
Holy Shit and wouldn't let go of me and
had me and it was hurting my neck badly,
no security,
nobody there days and I took the
microphone and I shoved it up his ass
and he got so paranoid that I had done
that,
that he ran away.
I don't know why.
All I know is I don't know if he had a
homophobic,
frightened moment or thought maybe that
I was going to go further in or maybe
that he would have farted and I would've
picked it up on the mic.
But in any case,
that is scary when you are out there
with the people.
Now young girls will just flash me their
boobs and go,
Danny Tanner,
you know,
like that.
But uh,
I've had a few things like that happen
where people have had to,
security has had to throw people out.
You've got all kinds of stuff like that.
That won't happen to you in Irvine at
the Improv.
I hope not.
You got a hell of a standup career
happening because you have so many.
So you say content and then you have
jokes you're going to have.
You're going to talk philosophically
like you do on here about life,
and then you button it with something
humorous or you feather it throughout
with jokes.
Yeah.
Uh,
I mean,
I think we talked about this a little
bit,
but,
um,
you know,
there's two ways that you can do this.
So there's the Seinfeld way,
which is like that perfect tactician
laid out every pause,
every inflection point.
I could never do it that way.
I don't think that's exactly how you do
it either.
No,
but then there's sort of the garry
shandling way,
which was,
you know,
there's that great moment in the
documentary comedian where he shows him
his papers and it looks,
you know,
Hitler wrote it because it's like,
so perfect.
And then,
uh,
you have Gary Shandling who pulls out
this crumbled piece of paper that's much
closer to what I am.
I have some ideas.
And I did.
I was on a beach last week in Florida
and I wrote out the hour and some of it
is stuff that I've done through the
years that I've just updated,
but it's all based in what I'm doing
here and I'm trying to just be true.
I'm just trying to be.
It'd be great.
Yeah.
And then you're,
then you're hooked and then you then
welcome until the next 30 years and
it'll,
it'll infiltrate this and might not only
be stand up and you,
it's an interesting thing to do to be
able to go,
hey,
I'm going to do Vegas three times this
year and,
and uh,
you know,
and people come to see me and it's kind
of fun.
And can I get on the jet with you and
Mar?
You know what,
if I,
if I rock it for the next year,
that'll be my goal.
You saw the picture.
I saw the picture.
You don't want to be on that.
You don't want to be in that one.
That was a,
that was a fun trip.
That was a fun,
fun.
Can you guys do that every year?
You and Margaret,
I've never done it with before.
He always has a,
he has eddie vedder do it,
comes in and we didn't know.
We had him on tape and we had Reggie
Brown who did his Obama impression that
he's done on a real time before and then
he always had different people.
He gets different comedians to come out
and do it with him and he asked me to do
it because he wanted to have some fun
and we've always liked each other.
I mean we've known each other since for
23.
We all started together.
I took Jerry Seinfeld to Disneyland,
Jesus and Garry shandling and George
Wallace and it was the opening of
thunder mountain railroad.
And I'll leave you with this because
I've left you with nine other important.
Want to keep going now to uh,
but uh,
there was a goat with dynamite on.
Have you ever been on Thunder Mountain
Railroad?
I know it,
but I'm not exist anymore.
Oh,
it's very popular.
So there's a goat with dynamite.
A robot.
Not,
not much of a robot,
but it's trying to exactly where the
dynamite and you hear it.
And all I did for 23 years old and
Jerry's a few months older than me.
I think I,
I want Jerry.
Oh my God.
I go with dynamite.
And Gerry would,
Gerry always did,
was just lay out the obvious,
oh my gosh,
our glass with a stain,
you know,
that's not a joke or I'm not him because
he's brilliant business.
There's nothing to clean glass.
But,
but he to this day I could say,
oh my God,
I go with dynamite and he will laugh
because it's when you know somebody and
you just get them,
you know.
And I saw a bunch of comics last night,
so Paul Riser and it was billy crystal's
birthday and it's just nice seeing all
these people that I.
Yeah.
So magical that time.
Right?
Like you came up in a time that to me
and for anyone that appreciates comedy,
it's like,
Holy Shit,
all of these guys.
And then you realize there weren't that
many.
You go like,
oh,
there were thousands of comedians.
No,
there weren't.
There were hundreds and a lot of them
are gone.
And then there's,
you know,
I'm at that two thirds point,
I'd like to think my middle chapter I,
it means I have to live to 122.
Well,
with all the medications these days,
I think it's possible anything's
motorized,
unicycle up my butt,
but no seat that seems excessive,
but whatever,
whatever works for you.
And we lost Stephen Hawking.
Just wanted to end on that.
You mentioned George Wallace,
George Wallace,
his hbo special,
which I think maybe he only had one,
which is a real disservice,
although he's had many other specialists
to me might be the funniest half hour.
There was something about him and he was
always.
A friend of mine always rented Jerry's.
Yeah,
he's just a funny,
funny guy.
And um,
he would mess with me one time he was
opening for Tom Jones a lot on the road
and I lived in Hollywood on Camino and
he went out of town,
but I forgot that he went out of town
and we were buddies and,
and,
um,
and he said,
he called me up.
He said,
saget make me chicken.
I said,
okay.
I had no life,
you know,
I was waiting for the comedy store that
night.
Know I was 24 maybe.
Okay.
I'll make you a chicken.
What do you want to southern fried in an
oven.
Okay,
sure.
Maybe make,
does make me chicken.
I'll be over in a couple hours.
So I make chicken and make a whole bunch
of chicken is already so put that and
then he doesn't come over and now I'm
getting worried.
William Holden had just died.
And so I'm like scared that George died
and his conduct shows you how I have
grown as a human.
I called his landlord and uh,
I got ahold of a building and he,
George is in Tahoe is nobody can Tom
Jones.
So I called the hotel and there's a
George W.
What did you do?
He said,
you fucking idiot.
I told you I was opening for Tom Jones.
Why'd you make me chicken?
I said I'm freezing it and you're going
to eat it.
Dammit.
So that's the end of that story.
The George Wallace ever eat your
chicken.
No,
I ate it.
It was pretty good.
On that note,
saget.
I've made chicken sense until I came to
your house and I saw your.
The way you were eyeballing the one on
the left.
You can have an egg.
You can have the chicken.
Okay.
Can I have an egg?
Yeah,
you can leave this house with an egg.
I want.
I'm going to give you a farm.
Fresh egg and I happy.
Do I cook it?
You know,
happy.
That'll make my sister Bob Saget.
Danny Tanner.
He's walking out of my house with a
farm.
Fresh egg.
But can I eat it?
Yeah.
This is what I will cook it.
You know what?
David's the chef around here.
Do you want to literally the best sunny
side up egg.
All right.
We are ending this show.
This really has been a pleasure.
It's so nice when you meet somebody who
you know,
who you know,
but you don't know,
and then you realize you that you know
them.
Something like that.
That's the point I think of what we're
supposed to do as people.
We get to do this and we would do this
at dinner.
This is almost like this,
except we just.
We would move more,
didn't move very much.
I was like,
you know,
Captain Pike a little bit.
Yeah.
All right.
I suspect we'll do this over dinner
again and we'll do it here again.
And uh,
and this is,
I think you've got enough to edit this
for three years.
This is the longest.
Sheila,
this is actually my retirement show now.
How long was this?
About six hours.
That's fantastic.
Now really this was beyond,
we went into mountain time for more on
that man.
Bob Saget checkout his special zero to
60 on Amazon,
and we've got the link right down below.